now do you know why i don't wear them  all the time  why because  when i wear the glasses i look exactly  like rachel maddow and this is no joke  ben shapiro came up to me one time he  goes  michael  you got to lose the glasses i said what  are you talking about he said  conservative conservatives don't wear  the glasses i said yes what i say yeah i  said why this is actually didn't even  occur to me at this point because you  were still stuck in the car in the  middle of the woods yeah i said no  plenty of plenty of political people on  tv wear glasses he said who i said you  know  rachel maddow uh lawrence o'donnell uh  chris matthews uh chris hayes uh there  was all the libs i couldn't name a  single conservative on tv you might be  the one exception  only the libs wear glasses i never  thought of it only the lips because we  can see so clearly ourselves well so  that means i got it wrong we got it  wrong you have to drink i'll drink in  salt okay